[Music]
in crazy lady news submitted by stranger
danger that's right a fitness guru was
jailed after threatening her rivals on
Instagram I like fitness guru drama
smart me too I love when people take
fitness so seriously
haha it's not funny anything seriously
is fine so this chick is bonkers so
she's a mother of four no okay no well
one of her kids got involved in this
[ __ ] which is [ __ ] up so her name is
Tammy Stefan look anybody where first
first two names it's weird she's a
fitness star she looks like a meth
addict to me okay okay never mind but
that's still kind of messy Neffe but
that's that bikini look yeah like
there's that but the mugshot picture I
think I think when when white people
have sucked up faces and have a mud
mugshot picture it just looks messy true
so she's 37 years old
this [ __ ] created 369 Instagram
accounts that's a lot of work Oh 18
email addresses kudos to her with four
kids right she is she works harder than
some of our trolls and she's still mom
which is the hardest job that is because
our trolls just sit around and jackoff
all day so they don't have much to do
but they work off that's a lot but how
much jackin can you do cuz she's
probably like still getting her Fitness
on taking care of kids and she's
trolling
I hope she's taking care of her kids oh
you're right she might be just bad maybe
she's gonna set up where she has she's
on the treadmill like walking on the
treadmill while she's on her computer
she's efficient yeah I've seen this yeah
yeah very efficient so she used these
accounts to harass her ex business
partner at a gym at a tempo gym and her
competitors in the bodybuilding world so
one message the tool you don't [ __ ]
use the proteins right or some [ __ ] like
I don't know
yeah more like 2% body fat Wallace jabs
so one Instagram account that is called
cat lover expressed that she ran she
sent a message saying I plan to slice
you up into little pieces shell taste I
like the shower when it's too extreme
I'm like you're trying too hard it's
very nice yes so this girl she cyber
stalked
cyber stuff because what they're calling
it she cyberstalked five victims in
three states
and there were all Fitness people
everyone yet it's a it's a competitor's
a competitor partner and then so like
for example one of them
she had a headless baby doll where she
wrote like inside the doll there was a
note that said new toy for the kids
and she claimed that like she reported
it that someone left that item on the
front porch of her house but the cops
were like oh like I guess she didn't get
the results that she wanted from the
cops so five days later she came up with
this kidnapping scheme where she involve
Daisy her 12 year old daughter and so
she 12 year-old daughter had been
feeding the family's dog when a Hispanic
man tried to say hey what the [ __ ] hey
he was Hispanic she was trying to think
of a realistic race no let me tell you I
got a realistic race you should hurry
and hit click the subscribe button as
fast as you can
that's one way to find out the real
culprit hit subscribe quickly though to
end racism hit subscribe that's right oh
wow they ended it
somehow some people didn't hit subscribe
that's why it's still here
they all did
hit subscribe or us event ends okay so
they the reason why she still it was a
Hispanic man trying to snatch her
daughter and drag her into the woods oh
and also she said that the kid had
urinated out of fear but it turns out
that that she was trying to pin it on
her former business partner because I
guess that's because he's Hispanic I'm
assuming the way they report this and
then so oh because also there was this
laptop case hidden in a bush and inside
there was a notepad filled with personal
information about her in her home and so
she had the daughter described the
attacker and then also like the police
took that very seriously so he used
helicopters and dogs to search the woods
but then wouldn't you scared shitless if
you made up some [ __ ] and like don't
worry we got the dogs on it I'd be like
oh [ __ ] guess what she wanted though she
wanted yeah so she's like thank God I
hope the dogs find the [ __ ] that I left
at his house or something hmm
Yeah right she probably planned itself
but then the cops became suspicious when
her daughter questioned what what
happened to her mother if she told the
truth so then she sucks at lying
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's gonna happen at swabby speaker
right I know but you wouldn't say stuff
like that if you had some street smarts
well I mean do you think her daughter
had street smarts I know maybe she knows
about brown rice and egg whites and
stuff yeah so then they question
hypothetically if somebody was lying in
this situation they'd go to jail so then
the police found a Walmart surveillance
footage of her purchasing the laptop
cover and a blue notebook and they
concluded that she had even forced her
daughter to urinate on her Oh mio create
the whole scheme here she small aided
herself
yeah I could pee on myself pretty easy
though even in that case they found even
in that case they had surveillance
footage of the people buying the ship
same ship crew was it a Walmart truck it
was a Lowe's or something yeah you mean
those African white supremacists yeah
yeah yeah dude the word of the world of
white supremacist change African
bodybuilder whites approve yes the
bodybuilding African white supremacists
the bodybuilding African white
supremacists that's a good screen name
if you want a good screen name out there
bodybuilding she probably has a lot of
girls for instance um again how did you
make that many accounts so much hate in
our rating so she was arrested on
charges of filing a false police report
tampering with evidence and child
neglect and then they added witness
tampering charges days later after she
called her daughter from a jail phone
which is a record and she told her
daughter to claim responsibility for the
kidnapping plot she said you won't get
in trouble but I will charge on top of
it what if the phones are recorded right
exactly I would yeah
like the fitness community from the
outsider just like oh it's like a bunch
of coaches trying to help people okay
six-packs or whatever but since I'm in
it I hear all kinds of drama and I'm
like how the [ __ ] is there so much drama
in this world of just like getting
biceps and like quads and stuff I've
seen so much drama in that world like
especially from people obviously
doctoring photos is a big thing and then
sucking in for pictures is a big thing
no thirst crazier drama where it's like
dudes are beating their the girl their
girlfriends or there's dudes that are
big body boiler dudes that like to [ __ ]
dudes for money wow it's just like a
bunch I'm like this is gay for pay gay
for pay type stuff and I saw that one
guy [ __ ] a grapefruit it was funny yeah
and they're just like whoa and then
don't be like people that are beefing
like Tupac and Biggie type [ __ ] and I'm
like aren't you guys just flexing in
front of the mirror like what's what's
so serious about she was doing this [ __ ]
too cuz then she would even make threats
on like her victims and the lives of
their family and friends yeah I think
what's so serious about OK doing bicep
curls wait so are the body build there's
like crazier or the athletes crazier
like which ones more crazier
we need more steroids what do you mean
which would you know like athletes as in
like people like like a football star a
basketball star yeah like people that
are into like sports and cuz I think
bodybuilding and doing shows is more
subjective versus like an objective game
or like act like an Olympian or like
something like that
yeah what's with the orange tanning oil
Oh cuz uh so what they're trying to do
is since you get judged on a stage you
have to they do that to pretty much use
the stage lights to show like muscle
separation conditioning to the person in
the back row that's what they have to
are also they don't create shadow flex
on stage like contouring so bright just
so bright I'll just get washed out so
you have so much man yeah but you have
to cuz you're flexing on stage you're
not like flexing in front of a person
and and then usually they get they have
such white teeth it's like shesh your
cat it's part of it
and it's very already look closely the
Flex is so hard that they're kind of
shaking what percent body fat do you
have to be in order to at the highest
level yeah like three oh my god that's
like borderline starving and dying see
every single green and the [ __ ]
muscle that's hot red fibers bro three
percent that looks like it's just skin
and the muscles about to burst this fear
they're only that way for that one day
though oh five percent after thirty six
because I'm like how can you survive on
three percent bond no they're only there
for that day they peak for it for that
week and then they immediately come
right off for people who don't know
generally peep like normal people around
like twenty percent normal like every
day a normal fit person is 20% also what
about walking like David's probably
fifty and then like persons probably
thirty and forty oh yeah so people that
move in an occasionally gym or like
they're fit but not like Instagram fit
is twenty
yeah like twenty you could already see
like app contours maybe not the full
six-pack but you can see app contours
already what people typically like like
when you know and you're like all that
that guy looks kind of lean cuz the most
people don't want like crazy vascularity
they just want I like that
most people are looking at 15 or 18 yeah
what people like that's true wait so the
people that compete is it who can push
it to the limit and body before yeah
like some bodybuilding for that specific
sport they judge on like muscle size
cemetry balance like how your shoulders
because their goal is trying to be like
a Greek sculpture guy so they're trying
to like they're it's actually more of an
art form than it is a sport yeah that's
what I meant by not really using the
word athlete but it's a it seems like
more like an aesthetic goal of sculpting
rather than like a performance goal of
achieving some type of skill or
something yeah it's like a human
sculpture and even the way like you
you'd the poses that you choose my
arnold invented this pose you'll see him
a lot of pictures because he has abs are
kind of weak but even got big biceps so
you fight over poses happens do they
fight over poses like you're expelling
mine that's my opinion
no mines actually like this that's my
pulse not by Arnold invented this pose
to cover his abs and he compresses a
bicep so you can showcase haha dude wow
that is just a whirl
yeah but anyway this chick here she
survived right so who [ __ ] jail [ __ ]
five years
[Music]
[Music]